you spend probably enough time with the
math and the photons
can you
put yourself in that space so we're like
having a conversation pretty peaceful
comfortable flat space are you able to
put yourself in in a place around a
black hole yeah I'm able to imagine that
kind of thing yeah so for example and
actually there's a wonderful movie
um
Interstellar yeah and
in that movie you know Kip Thorne of
course is a great
theoretical physicists experimental who
later won the Nobel Prize
um for ligo
and that movie is very accurate
scientifically
and there's some funny statements in
there
that
of the
you know 100 million people who saw that
movie there can't be more than 10 or 20
understood
about why Matthew McConaughey is
ejecting the trash in a certain
direction in order to
but you know for example if I were a
spinning black hole right here if I was
spinning fast enough
you wouldn't be able to stay still there
you'd be have to be orbiting around like
that you know you'd have to have your
microphone on them but I wonder what the
experiences with the actual experience
because I mean space itself is curved
well space gets very curved you get
crushed
you know the body gets ripped apart
because the forces are different on
different parts sure okay so that would
be but if it but if it can be less
curved so that the curvature is very
noticeable but you're not ripped apart
the fact that this was just nonchalantly
stated is is just beautiful like two
biological systems discussing uh which
level of curvature is required to rip
apart said biological system very well